this is bloomberg breakfast
i've always been fascinated by what
motivates our business leaders and i
want to know what we can learn from
their stories nick welcome to bloomberg
welcome to bloomberg breakfast
from a space above a restaurant in
london to an empire of over 30 members
clubs the last 17 years has seen cell
house expand across the world from la to
istanbul to the beaches of mykonos and
the prime real estate of chelsea new
york it's become a hunt for creatives
and celebrities and even bankers with
the opening of the ned in the city of
london
in the middle of the pandemic nick made
a bold move and took the company public
so how'd you start your morning i start
my morning with a very early alarm call
but i'm finding the older i get
the i just naturally wake yeah how early
i i like waking up at
5 00 5 30. that's like a bloomberg and
then i like
going for a bit of exercise yeah so
every day
not maybe four times a week so if i'm in
london i
take some boxing on regent's park one
americano sir thank you very much
beautifully done
breakfast is always very important
what's your favorite well
bold eggs are pretty well my favorite
but
usually i i'm so fussy i only do them at
home
i i've never been part of a private
member's club apart from sarah hacks and
i think probably
you know when i went to new york i was
never able to get into any of the clubs
so he said i'm gonna find my own so i
thought maybe maybe this is one way of
sorting that out
you have quite a journey do you ever
stop to think wow um
sometimes
what do you think about
well i sort of think
it started so small and
there seems to be so much demand for
more
you know what we created 27 years ago
seems incredibly relevant in today's
life in the fact that people want to
live this sort of more flexible
uh hybrid way of living and you know
physical connection is never going away
um
food and drink and sleeping is never
going away people want to socialize they
want to
to connect and so a house in soho works
is ideal for that bring me back to that
day in 1993.
the day in 93 was when i got the phone
call from the landlord to say would you
want to take the space available
upstairs and i went well
never shy of an opportunity i hadn't
looked around and i thought what could i
do there and because it had a small door
i thought well it can only be a private
members club so
it was three houses with three floors in
the middle of soho so it was a house in
soho so we called it her house
and we went round um the area and found
500 incredible founder members which
still with you today they are still with
us today and it sort of grew from there
it was like a starting with a very small
snowball and then growing and growing
and growing but at the time did you have
plans already or did you just think let
me get this i i've only ever been led by
our members so
when it looked like it was beginning to
work our members would say wouldn't it
be so great if we could have a version
of this in the countryside
so i went okay yes so we created
babington house and then they would say
well wouldn't it be great if there was
one in new york and i got friends and
people who come over
to london from new york say this would
work so well in new york so we ended up
doing one in new york and so really
i've always been led by our members and
wherever our members suggest i usually
follow did you think when you were young
that you wanted to be an entrepreneur
no i didn't i i was highly dyslexic at
school um i struggled at school
and i just thought you know how do i
just get through this part of my life
and i was excited about that because
even though i was happy at school i
i i felt that
me and an exam paper and being told what
to do by a teacher was not really what i
wanted to do i wanted to have more of a
free spirit what do you define yourself
as is it entrepreneur restaurateur
caterer
when i went into um hospitality yeah i
went straight into the kitchen and when
i went into the kitchen i was surrounded
by by people who i would never have met
or come into contact unless i was
working in the kitchen and it was such a
great eye-opener and they were such
decent nice people but it was you you
just learn how to get on with people and
i think when i at that stage i was a
very shy guy so
it was it was good to learn and so at
the time what was your first business so
did you think actually i need to i need
to do things i need to be an
entrepreneur because i set up over the
top restaurant which was
really bad so why were they bad well it
was the food was bad the decor was bad
the service was bad
and you know i i owe it to my friends
who came
regularly to support me
and they had to eat quite a lot of
horrible food but were you down in the
dumps when you realized or did you take
it well i don't know i i felt i was
learning all the time i was learning if
i did this differently would would that
work and would if i tweet that and have
i change that so then i opened cafe
boehm in 92 and then sewer house opened
in 95. so what's your biggest mistake
that you learned from
i the biggest mistake was not to realize
that any of it was a mistake but to
learn by it
and
and and just that it was just a journey
and it was progression and i think i
still do that every day so you've had so
how since 1993 a lot has happened since
then we've become more digitized we had
covered what was the hardest day in this
journey
i think it's been lots of hard days i
think there's been lots of days where
we've run out of money
um
and in the early days and you had to
figure out your way through that
um
and
you know i care deeply about our members
and our
our people who work for us so
you know when anything happens to them
that's a hard day in in those early days
when you ran out of money
do you i mean what do you do do you
swear do you kind of stay positive or
how well i swear to myself
and and and
but you learn never to do that again you
learn again
how
do i
figure out how that doesn't happen are
you always positive are there days where
you just think no i think i think there
are days when i'm i'm challenging you
know i'm challenging to the team and if
you're not
if you always look at everything
you know that it's great then you're not
going to then challenge them to try and
make it better so there's a bit of both
you know in the next three years we're
going to be at 85 houses globally you
know it's all about teamwork it's all
about a culture it's all about
people aiming to make the life of a
member better do you worry about
over-expansion like as an entrepreneur i
guess you choose what city you want to
open in
well
i i i
you know ever since we went from one to
two people went oh
you know it's gonna change and actually
i think
what we found is
the the more global we've become the
more interesting a place we are to come
and work and
i think
we never take anything for granted we
always go into a new city nervous and
thinking that we have to make it has to
work locally if it doesn't work locally
it never works globally what's your
biggest challenge every time you open a
house is it location is it staff
shortages is it
i mean talking big picture it's it's
it's it's
it's making sure you get to the right
right city into the right location and i
think we have a cities with our houses
so we already have members in those
cities who
care about us so they guide us to the
right area of the city and they guide us
to the right building so
and and and staffing yes we got a
short-term
problem with staffing at the moment like
everyone does it doesn't matter if it's
hospitality it doesn't mean
whoever you are and i think you just
have to just get better at employing
people you have to be
go we've come with the times you've got
to you've got to you've got to figure
new ways of encouraging people into your
business does stuff get stolen at the
houses
borrowed
borrowed and given back sometimes
permanently borrowed sometimes
i don't know if you have a party trick
but how do you make a successful dinner
party well
i think the sense of generosity
and to make sure
that it feels
casual enough that it relaxes people um
you know so lots of lots of lots of lots
of drinks lots of
sense of good music good company
um and and low expectation i think you
know don't build it up as if it's going
to be something special and i think
people always
enjoy themselves when it's a surprise so
no paper invite no paper invite word of
mouth text maybe and maybe even over
invite so you're having to add chairs so
it looks oh i'm glad i'm here rather
than having empty spaces nick jones
thank you so much thank you very much
for having me on
[Music]